bonjour à toutes et à tous bon bah toute
l'équipe 2 de sciences est parti en
vacances
voilà sauf moi merci les gars et du coup
je me suis dit que plutôt que de vous
faire un épisode sur la solitude et la
nocivité de partager des photos de
vacances sur facebook
je suis allé dans les archives et je
vous ai trouvé des vieux épisodes deux
aces de science à l'époque ça s'appelait
écorces de recherche
alors je vous laisse visionner
[Musique]
nous sommes en 1951 et les derniers
miracle de la technologie permettent
désormais au savon de voir le sont
[Musique]
toutes nos salutations cher spectatrices
et spectateurs
imaginez un instant vous vous rendez
dans une salle de concert pour apprécier
la quatrième symphonie de brahms et là
quel malheur vous l'entendez pas les
envolées lyriques des violons mais un
brouhaha insupportable
sans compter que votre voisin mange
bruyamment du maïs soufflé pour
s'assurer que toutes salles de concert
ou de conférences jouisse d'une qualité
acoustique irréprochable il faudrait
d'abord mieux comprendre la propagation
du son à l'intérieur de sa ligne sauf
qu'il ya un léger problème
le son est un vivier vous ne le savez
peut-être pas mais le son se propage
sous forme d'un monde
regardez bien ces images
vous êtes maintenant sous vous allez
faire exactement ce jeu lui dire non
c'est une farce il ne s'agit pas d'un
dispositif de charlatans et snow teaser
mais bien dans simulateur d'onde sonore
utilisé par le centre de recherche
scientifique maritime et industriels de
marseille et ce système déborde
d'ingéniosité parfois ils débordent
réellement il s'agit d'une cuve à fond
plat et transparents remplis d'eau
éclairé par un arc électrique je vous
présente la cuve aride
et lorsque je dis reid je ne parle pas
de désert
je parle des rides qui sont produites à
la surface de l'eau ce sont elles qui
représente les ondes sonores
voici l'image des vides projeté sur
l'écran lorsque l'on place une surface
l'équivalent d'un mur dans la cuve
arides les réflexions des ondes
provoquent des interférences gênante
elles se traduisent par un dessin en
damier occupant la plus grande partie de
l'écran c'est là où les sons se
mélangent pour tester l'acoustique d'une
mauvaise salle de conférence les
scientifiques ont placé une maquette de
cette salle au sein du dispositif
voyez l'enchevêtrement problématique des
ondes réfléchies
une étude préalable sur la maquette
aurait donc permis d'éviter les erreurs
de construction
ceci est donc à bill est utile une
surface spéciales comme celle fille
appelée police y diffuse les sont
uniformément dans toutes les directions
on utilise notamment des murs de cette
forme dans les studios de radio
diffusion
mais attention nos chercheurs des
centres de recherche scientifique
maritime et industriels de marseille ont
plus d'un tour dans leur sac
c'est indigne plus d'une maquette dans
leurs laboratoires
cette fois les chercheurs vont réussir à
créer un modèle de la répartition du son
dans une pièce c'est donc une autre
façon de voir le sont avec les yeux
et plutôt que d'utiliser des rides sur
l'eau nos savants utilise des ultrasons
dans l'air chez son sont tellement ému
que nous autres humains ne pouvons les
entendre contrairement à nos compagnons
à quatre pattes je parle bien entendu de
nos chiens et non pas de nos chaises
réfléchie par la surface a étudié les
ultrasons sont captés par un microphone
comme vous pouvez le voir sur cette
admirable graphisme explicatif le
microphone et mobiles et va explorer
l'espace par ligne par len ce microphone
va alors commandé l'intensité lumineuse
une petite lampe qui va se déplacer
devant du papier photographique ainsi le
papier va enregistrer la répartition des
ondes sonores dans la salle voici les
résultats
on appelle cela la topographie
acoustique d'une salle
vous savez maintenant que grâce à
différents modèles réduits les savants
peuvent désormais mieux comprendre la
réponse acoustique d'une structure et
espérons le nous permettre de mieux
profiter de nos concerts et nos
conférences scientifiques
ce sont donc des recherches qui
certainement vont faire du bruit
[Musique]
n'oublie pas de brancher votre
transistors sur la bonne faïence pour le
moc et aucun épisode des corses de
recherche